hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
since the original iPhones launched 13
years ago a lot of people have been
waiting for Apple's next big product
category since then we've had the iPad
Apple watch an ear pods
these have all sold well but I think
Apple's next venture into augmented
reality might be more interesting
augmented reality is a technology whose
goal it is to augment or enhance one's
physical environment by adding digital
elements we explored augmented and
virtual reality and their history in a
previous video so you can check that out
to learn a bit of background this new
industry has started maturing and Apple
stepping in with a pair of augmented
reality glasses may be a game changer
the details of these glasses were
recently leaked so what can Apple bring
to the space sit back relax and enjoy as
we dive in you are watching ColdFusion
TV
from previous patent filings we know
that Apple has been exploring virtual
and augmented reality technologies for
more than ten years the company has
established a secret research unit
comprising of hundreds of employees
including members from companies such as
Microsoft Lytro magic leap oculus and
organizations such as NASA and Virginia
Tech they've also acquired a bunch of
companies in the AR and VR space from
Google glass and snapchat spectacles to
hololens
magic leap and Facebook's upcoming AR
glasses many have tried and are trying
to make this technology work and the
landscape could suddenly get very
crowded very fast but so far it's mostly
been in vain there hasn't been any
mainstream success beyond the dedicated
tech community and Apple may change that
if there's one thing that Apple is good
at its making technology simple for the
masses in the 80s they changed personal
computing by popularizing or stealing
depending on how you look at it Xerox is
graphical user interface it changed
computers from lines of text that were
often confusing frustrating and
error-prone into a graphical interface
that everyone could understand in 2001
they made portable music less of a chore
to navigate and of course in 2007 Apple
made smartphones accessible they took
the clunkiness out of the user interface
before the iPhone it was the buttons of
a blackberry or the frustrating
touchscreen of an LG Prada capacitive
multi-touch changed the game all of this
is to say having simplicity at the core
has proved to be a successful strategy
for Apple and a new product category
like augmented reality is the perfect
arena to push the strategy further Lika
John Prosser says that these new glasses
will be called Apple glass he mentioned
that the product will look similar to
Ray Bans or the glasses that Tim Cook
wears he describes them as
unintimidating a factor that I think
will be very important the price is said
to be $4.99 which is surprising for
Apple for instance microsoft's hololens
2 has a price tag of $3500 I've got
another app here called the euphoria of
view now it's a little big so let me
just use two hands here to make it
smaller and then rotate it so you can
see there we go and then they put it
down here in your space film a bit
smaller yeah that's nice alright now
let's switch gears and talk about a
different kind of application I've got a
browser over there but it's kind of far
away and I don't really want to walk
over there so let me just call it over
with my voice follow me alright so let
me just open up that Start menu here and
then place the app and then launch it I
don't really want it following me around
though along showing you all this cool
stuff so let me just put it over here
and then we'll get back to it later but
much of that cost comes from all the
electronics needed to run the AR
experience being built into the headset
itself on the other hand Apple glasses
are said to be run from the
phone much like the first generation
Apple watch but we'll get to this later
each lens is said to have a resolution
of 8k which puts it above most TVs the
release date for the glasses is said to
be around 2022 according to the leaks
there's going to be no cameras on the
glasses for privacy reasons in the
context of wearing glasses having a
camera pointed at you when someone is
looking at you will be off-putting to
many and this problem was one of the
main reasons why Google glass failed so
if there's no camera the question has to
be asked how will Apple glass be able to
see the environment to make all of the
AR happen well that's going to be done
with a technology called lidar lidar
stands for laser imaging detection and
ranging it uses lasers to scan an
environment and visualize distance and
the shape of objects it's similar to how
bats use sound waves to quote see their
surroundings lidar sensors are also used
in self-driving cars Apple already uses
this technology in their latest iPad pro
in the iPad pro the lidar scanner is
already good enough to create a detailed
mesh of its surroundings it can
recognize furniture people and more the
iPad pro and the next iPhone could end
up acting like a development kit for the
glasses sensors analyst Ming chiku
expects the AR glasses to be marketed as
an iPhone accessory and as mentioned the
computation processing networking and
positioning data will all be offloaded
to the iPhone the iPhone already has AR
and computer vision computation ships
built right in so it seems like Apple
designed these phones with the glasses
in mind offloading all the processing to
the iPhone will allow the glasses to
remain slim and lightweight
according to a Bloomberg report there's
a new Apple patent that allows the
streaming of information from your phone
to your face
specifically the glasses quote are
expected to synchronize with aware as
iPhone to display things such as text
emails maps and games over the users
field of vision end quote
Apple also has plans for third-party
apps and is considering a dedicated app
store you could easily imagine
navigation software or the enabling of
home entertainment on a Reese callable
virtual TV according to another patent
the system will be capable of
identifying vision problems and
automatically adjust the refraction of
the displays and lenses to help a user
see this eliminates the need to wear
prescription lenses beneath the
augmented reality device Bloomberg has
also said that the glasses will run on
our OS or reality operating system Ras
is said to be based on iOS there's
already code in iOS 13 indicating a
stereoscopic software called star board
this takes a bit of its name from the
springboard which is what the iPhones
home screen interface is called iOS 14
is said to have support for a handheld
controller remote there are displays in
both lenses and the user interface can
be controlled by performing gestures on
the frames or by using your hands in
front of them augmented reality apps and
games have been available since iOS 11
thanks to a arquette now there's a huge
range of apps and games blending digital
objects with the real world
AR kit has demonstrated that Apple
already has all the tech to do this
today and these software releases may
have been in preparation for the glasses
this whole time
since the launch of this new product
category and platform is still a while
away the details could be subject to
change that being said the information
and leaks are very interesting as
someone who's happy to see consumer tech
progress I'd love to see how Apple goes
about tackling the AR problem
their thoughts of simplicity and
attention to detail when it comes to
user experience could go a long way in
pushing augmented reality into the
mainstream so what do you guys think
about all of this not so much from the
point of views Apple as a brand but the
bigger picture of augmented reality and
where it's heading let me know in the
comments section below
if you're interested in more background
and history behind augmented reality and
virtual reality I'll leave a link for
the previous episode on this topic below
it's pretty interesting and I'm sure
you'll learn something
up next I'm thinking of doing a video on
the history of ColdFusion and Who I am
as a person sort of like those draw my
life videos that youtubers were doing a
few years back but of course without the
drawing I'm still thinking about it
anyway thanks for watching if you did
enjoy that video and want to see more on
science technology history or business
feel free to subscribe to this channel
so my name is to go go and you've been
watching ColdFusion and I'll catch you
again soon for the next video cheers
guys have a good one
ColdFusion its new thinking
you